you're uh you got a nobel prize for uh
looking out into the trying to reach
back into the beginning of the universe
listening to the gravitational waves
uh
but that still doesn't answer the why
why are we here
beyond just the yeah the matter and
anti-matter
the philosophical question i felt a
philosophical question about the meaning
of life i'm probably not really good at
um
i think
that
the individual meaning
uh
i i would say rather simplistically is
whether you've made
a difference a positive difference i'd
say for anything besides yourself
meaning you could
have been important to other people
or you could have discovered
gravitational waves that matters to
other people or something but something
beyond just existing on the earth
as an individual so
your life has meaning if you have
affected
um
either
knowledge or people or something beyond
yourself
do you that's a simplistic
statement but it's about as good as i
and i have that's that may
in all of its simplicity it may be very
true
do you think about uh
does it make you sad that this ride ends
do you think about your mortality
yeah uh
are you afraid of it
i'm not exactly afraid of it but
saddened by it and uh
you know i'm old enough to know that
i've
lived most of my life
and uh
uh
i enjoy being alive
i can imagine being sick and not wanting
to be alive but i'm not and
so uh
i'm
not getting a good ride
yeah i'm not ha and i'm not happy to see
it come to an end i'd like to see it
prolonged
but uh
i i don't uh
i i i don't
fear the dying itself or that kind of
thing it's more i'd like to prolong
what
is i think
a good life that i'm living and still
living that's kind of
it's sad to think that the the
finiteness of it
is the thing that makes it special
and it
and also sad to um
you know to me at least it's kind of
i don't think i'm using too strong of a
ward but it's kind of terrifying the
uncertainty of it
the mystery of it you know the mystery
of death the mystery of it yeah of death
when we're talking about the mystery of
black holes that's somehow distant
that's somehow out there and the mystery
of our own but but but even life the
mystery of consciousness i find uh so
hard to deal with too
i mean it's not as painful i mean we're
conscious but the whole magic of life we
can understand but consciousness where
we can actually think and
so forth it's pretty it's such it seems
like such a beautiful gift that it
really
sucks that uh we get to let go of it
we'll have to let go of it yeah what do
you hope your legacy is
as i'm sure they will uh aliens when
they visit and humans have destroyed all
of uh human civilization aliens read
about you and encyclopedia they will
leave behind what do you hope it says
well i would i would hope they
if to the extent that they evaluated me
felt that i helped move
science forward as a
tangible contribution and that
i served as a good role model for
how humans should live their lives
and we're part of creating one of the
most incredible things
humans have ever created
so yes there's the science that's the
fermi thing right yeah uh the and the
instrument i guess and the instrument
the
instrument is a magical creation not
just by a human by a collection of
humans the collaboration
is um
that's
that's humanity at his best
i i do hope
i do hope will last quite a bit longer
but if we don't
this is a good thing to remember humans
by
at least they built that thing
that's pretty impressive barry this is
an amazing conversation thank you so
much for wasting your time and
explaining uh so many things so well i
appreciate your time today thank you
you